wenn ja meine frage an dich wäre mal
warum bist du so wie du bist und warum
es zu so extravagant und ausgeflippt das
wäre schon mal eine kleine frage
software eine antwort zu kriegen
gegenfrage warum bist du so wie du bist
ich nehme mal an weil der liebe gott und
so geschaffen hat wie wir sind wir sind
nämlich genauso wie der liebe gott auch
göttlich weißt du wie sind nämlich
kleine blätter
und ich bin so wie ich bin weil der
spatz sowie der spatz ist und weil die
nina sowie den nina ist und weil die
märkte sowie merkel ist und weil die
friedenstaube sowie die friedenstaube
essen weil wie hieß ja noch mal egal und
weil wir so sind wie wir sind sind wir
so wie wir sind